oh what's that what'd you say about my
new shirt oh that's a that's a really
nice new
shirt just about my new that's sharp my
new uh
new rock stars wow look at your jealous
it's my new obsession now well i've just
been with this old thanos t-shirt
forever and here you are oh
i got a new shirt oh yeah that guy with
the with the paper weights
yeah yeah yeah with a really
consequential glove
yeah totally john you're in
you're in need of a new marvel show
we have a solid rotation and uh my
spider one's trapped in my car that's
being worked on guys we're gonna watch
them e.a vos today the king
the king of the easter eggs and the
breakdowns
canadian lads slowly creeping up on him
loki
episode three easter eggs and breakdown
let's keep the tradition going
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars i'm erik
voss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode three
lamentis in which loki and sylvie play a
game of
who is enchanting whom folks there's so
much to break down
already feels about the tva to asgardian
and other alien languages to translate
maybe even huge portions of this episode
that might be one of our variants
trapping the other in an illusion right
let's
loose the juice from our tin pad and
drop in the episode opens in
an illusion that the loki variant sylvie
placed tva hunter c20 under during the
events of episode 2.
so opening this episode in an illusion
instructs
us as viewers to watch this episode very
carefully because notice how over the
marvel studios title leading into this
we hear this music
this is called demons by haley kyoko
which is fitting for the way sylvia and
loki are called devils this episode
you're no travelers you're devils and
the way sylvie has been compared to a
demon in stained glass
and the lyrics of this song refer to
having demons in one's head and say
they're sitting in the water
all reflecting how silvie is in c20s
head
using a reconstructed memory of fruity
drinks to intoxicate
c20 into revealing tbac man
already already talk about a great
directional choice for
like a pop song that is more than just
setting the tone and mood for two girls
hanging out having fun
yeah like there's an actual meaning to
choosing this song you know it's
intentional everything about this show
feels very purposeful ah there's a
deeper meaning to these lyrics
yeah it's not just an ironic placement
it's actually got
themes that relate later this episode
sylvie reveals that this particular
memory from c20 was from hundreds of
years prior
from c20s passed as a human on earth
before she became a variant
confirming the theory that i shared in
last week's miss minutes video
that all tva employees are variants with
memories wiped and forced into servitude
by the time
that's why you're the man all kinds of
implications like perhaps
mobius was a jet ski salesman in his
past life maybe from san diego
judging from that snow globe in
rensselaer's office that mobius didn't
remember getting that could have been
dude so maybe wrestler could have been a
teacher or a principal at franklin d
roosevelt high school that that pen was
from but this also explains why c20 was
so
much real after coming out
showing that her visions of her past
life weren't just fantastical dreams but
subconscious memories of
real events remember b15 also looks
shaken
i suspect she too could have been linked
with her past life now the opening shot
at the end of the movie and that's why
they all look so confused
half drain reflecting the way c20s mind
is being drained by sylvie in this
moment they discuss brain freezes but
only c20 gets one
maybe sylvia doesn't get one because
loki variants are technically frost
giants they're not effectively cold
but check out that patron in the
background on the right looks a bit like
pietro mexico
i mean i only mentioned it because
sylvie's enchantment works similar to
wanda's hex reality which
also featured an ultimate reality pietro
in it there's actually a lot of
parallels like later when sylvie screams
in frustration her green screen is like
waterproof
like a shockwave similar to how wanda's
agonized scream created a shock
just could be a sign that variant loki's
could be potential nexus beings with
capabilities of setting the terms of a
single reality similar to how wanda can
do that
all right guys look listen yeah maybe or
it's just how women get mad at the mcu
yeah you gotta have a good power scream
don't come at me it's not a sexist
comment
it's it's just the dudes take off their
shirts this is the
right and now we'll find something else
special for the bisexual characters to
do
oh thank god yeah yeah they'll kiss
[Laughter]
or sing a song from their youtube no
bisexual characters are just going to
mention they're bisexual for a while
before we get that
going yeah and we'll never revisit that
just joking guys
i know all women can kick my ass
well not all they just scream
look out look out g the wrong scream
though you might get trapped in a hex
the whole other life you don't want to
live i'm just about to go but no in all
sincerity though yeah her magic while
it's more green wanda had my control
capabilities and so
she has her version of my control
capabilities
as well so it's both magic based so it
makes sense that some of the rules and
there will be parallels between what
they're doing they link credence to each
other by having some type of consistency
within the medium
and if you think about it wanted to
create the westview hex
out of grief over vision's absence and
what does loki say to sylvie here
you lack vision lack vision but the
illusions also work the same way
notice that moment c20 suspects
something is off about the reality
sylvie
switches it jumping ahead suddenly to
nighttime
similar to how whenever a glitch in the
matrix happened in west view wanda would
suddenly edit past it
and progress forward in time in that
case a sitcom decade forward
also sylvie grabs c20's wrist to get her
to refocus on her after the switch
showing how physical contact is needed
to form that neural link for the
enchantment now the music has changed to
deep blue by ladytron with lyrics
foreshadowing the whole journey ahead
for sylvia on lamantus one
seeking a power station on a train out
of town
hey by the way included in our loki
inspired merch is our latest augmented
reality shirt which when viewed through
an ar app
the god of mischief
[Music]
look out g i just bought this dude no
it's my time my time
and when you get that loki out of time
shirt you get an option to write in a
custom
shout out in our inside marvel after
show so he infiltrates the tva passing
this poster that reads the timeline is
only as strong as its weakest moment
with his agent all tangled up in the
timeline ironic considering this is
exactly what soby has just done to the
dba but notice that tva cops scream as
silvia erases him
yeah his whale is digitally filtered
actually similar to the mainstream
neo scriptures
one of my favorite sound effects ever
here unplugging these
mine slaves and restoring them to their
natural states
i said that in the who review
like maybe that's what she's doing is
like
kind of i said specifically she's kind
of like neo and freeing mine
you should be on new rock stars you
deserve eric's job now and then once i
hit play
he's gonna be like here's why that's not
the case damn it here's my greg
specifically
it was wrong which might be why it seems
to bring her so much satisfaction to do
it loki snatches sylvie's temp pad and
depletes its juice
leaving them marooned on lamentist one
in the year 2077 as another planet is
about to collide with it
melancholia style actually kind of like
the way thanos grabbed a moon and threw
it at titan but lament is actually in
the comics it's an outworld planet on
the edge of cree space
it's from the annihilation prologue
issue which
six decades after xandar's off-screen
destruction by thanos prior to infinity
war
so perhaps we're now seeing the
aftermath of the nova corps inability to
protect xandar's colonies
which we know was a reference for this
episode based on the guards being named
private hudson and corporal hicks
how do we wait a minute oh it's only
listed in the credits yeah they didn't
say it in the episode
damn it well we also missed the fact
that they look like cobra commander
yes yeah i've heard that pointed out a
million times like all of them are just
co-recommended we gotta have the
subtitles for everything now
sylvie tries to enchant loki but her
magic flickers out on his head though
away it did with the tda
what was he doing what are you doing
yeah sylvie's reaction makes me think
loki in this moment might have tried to
rebound the spell and enchant her
from this moment on it's not really
clear if either have been enchanted but
it
is weird that the meteor shower outside
subsides after this despite this
oncoming planet coming closer
on the walk they bicker don't call me
variant i'm sorry about not calling some
faded photocopy of me loki good because
that's not who i am anymore
i'm sylvie now oh you changed your name
brilliant it's called an alias this
confirms that sylvie did begin a loki
variant but due to loki's sex fluidity
just takes a female form but the name
sylvia was an alias that she chose so
despite using the term enchant
a lot she's not exactly sylvie lushton
enchantress from the comics but really a
new character inspired by both lady loki
and enchantress and they enter this town
that is covered with alien lettering
which from what i can tell matches
neither the scroll language written on
rocket scanner and guardians of the
galaxy nor the established mcu cree
alphabet
making me wonder if this could be
zandarian but we don't really have a way
to translate but
that won't stop me folks so look at the
structure
and hand it over the tempo to charge it
that top word has six
characters okay using the substitution
decoding process i use for the
so we're looking at a sequence of one
two three two three four so then you
gotta do some guesswork based on really
whatever the most likely
yeah tend to be in combinations with
each other i'm wondering if those could
be
r-e-r-e and the word could be pre-rick
for pre-requirements and all those names
in red on the side being the names of
colonists given priority status for
evacuation
which is why this building would be the
one building left in town with the
lights on
is it that even important of a word
feature
hey every detail is important
you did all that oh that's ciphering and
we don't even know for sure if that's
what it even says
my guess is that the neon in the windows
says open
he said that he's out of the studio and
that's why this one was coming later
than usual
he was running he was pouring over
characters going
what two letters could repeat in a
sequence like that and not just be a
mishmash of vowels jesus i would never
but i love that eric voss does that i
hope someone at marvel will contact him
be like delete that out of the video
that is the key to the entire video
this is what i do with my time so sylvie
kicks open the door to the trailer only
to be blasted with a gun
which looks a lot like a recreation of
that moment that bride tried to get the
job on bud and kill billboard
i got two things referenced right you
need a bingo card for the next break
inside loki notices the woman's framed
photo with her husband
kind of looks like an eye to grant woods
american gothic but common misconception
that does not depict a married couple
but a farmer and his daughter
kind of similar to how loki and hela are
step siblings in the mcu but in norse
mythology hella is loki's daughter
so at the train station is a line
colonist is trying to evacuate including
some kids and you know that means camera
lens eye contacts
[Music]
there are these two guys that appear to
be winds which could be another
interesting matrix parallel
because in that woman the red dress
scene the wachowskis populated the
extras that bumped into neo
with twins twins twins oh really has a
way to evoke this dreamlike simulation
this could be another possible clue that
this may be loki or sylvie having a
chance
wow an illusion damn i heard that it
might be an illusion and honestly the
setup
just from this breakdown alone keying
you in for illusions
makes me feel like ah that theory sounds
plausible hearing all this
back too and this matrix references it's
making it sound even more likely that
this is an illusion but would that
perhaps undercut this episode by the
time you get to the next one when
there's such a crazy cliffhanger here of
like how are they going to get off this
planet and they come to find out it was
just an illusion
yeah how do you sell the stakes of that
still i don't believe it's an illusion
honestly i feel like that would kind of
like they want us to think
yeah yeah exactly it's 100 what it is
it's a good mislead though honestly and
watch her wrong in the opening credits
of the next
dude he just wakes right up we never
left the tba
now the wealthy getting elite access to
this train is a bit similar to bong joon
ho's snow peer in which he uses a train
that's kind of a marxist allegory
similar to how this train leads to no
one's escape from destruction now loki
has to sit in the backwards facing seat
on the train
trains also feature prominently in the
movie inception where
in the opening sequence nash and arthur
sit in a trained car backwards facing
the mark
saito who was actually trapped in their
false reality i mean i just find it
interesting that they called attention
to the scene like this
and after some indeterminate amount of
time sylvie wakes up
confused now facing the opposite
direction in the frame
and this was after loki had asked her
earlier how long do we have
12 hours or so and now sylvie refers to
her memory as
just blips of a dream at this point now
sylvie learned earlier than loki did in
her timeline that she was adopted and
had to teach herself magic make me think
that her mother figure from her timeline
might not have been frigga on one event
report that loki read in episode two
the name sylvie lauffy daughter appeared
the surname being instead of lauthy's
son son of laufey
daughter of lauffy so i wonder if
perhaps sylvie's maternal figure could
have been hella
who in her timeline might have been in
that battle against the frost giants in
which lauthy's offspring was taken as a
ward and that hella could have left an
impression on sylvie maybe even given
her that sword before hello was banished
by odyss sylvie also reveals how
interesting
managed to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a
postman
whilst running across time from one
apocalypse to another casey from the tva
he's the
dude of romantic reunion is the finale
perfect that's who it is and they're
gonna give each other decorative paper
weights
it's not the mailman from one division
no
it can't be she could be referring to
stan lee who did appear as a fedex
delivery driver in civil war and he
bragged about that to the watchers in
guardians volume two
also cameoed in the 2005 fantastic four
film as a mailman
some are also saying it could be that
delivery driver in west view but postman
reminds me of the song nick fury used to
inspire the name captain marvel
marvel sounds a lot better you know like
the marvelettes
wait oh yes wait a minute mr postman
fury was an interesting hearing for
sylvie but why not the person who ended
up taking that name
carol danvers because locals
and carol would have been a superpower
galaxy hopper whose whereabouts were
unknown from 1995 to 2018
so silvia wakes up to find loki's
singing that would be
awesome yeah i would love that that
would be a great surprise for captain
marvel to just completely steal the
focus when
sylvie shows up like hey babe and marvel
will get their first love making scene
higher further faster periods oh yeah
and
everyone online will love it
unequivocally
sylvie doesn't go down marvel confirms
their agenda all along
[Laughter]
now according to captions this is an
asgardian making this the first time
we've heard asgardian as a language in
the mcu
though it's really norwegian his lyrics
translate to
in stormy black mountains i wander alone
over the iceberg i pull myself forth
in the apple garden stands the maiden
fair and i sing
when will you come home loki drunk calls
back thor's move in the first thor film
and he tells somebody that he's not
drunk just full which is another
in joke because a norwegian to be full
means to be drunk
loki gives an answer to her chat about
what love is
love is a dagger but ultimately when
you reach for it
it isn't real they're calling the famous
soliloquy in shakespeare's macbeth when
macbeth hallucinates an imaginary dagger
this is a dagger
of loki's betrayal of sylvie with
everything they're going through being a
kind of dagger of loki's enchantment
now during the brawl notice how silvia
uses her crown as a weapon this is a
move that loki did in thor ragnarok
that's right you can barely make out
some writing on it they look like viking
runes similar to the ones that are
carved into mjolnir and stormbreaker in
this case they're kind of hard to
translate
but to me it looks like t
th no and then h s
u and then maybe s-u-p-n i don't know
there's like a dozen different norse
rune alphabets out there
let's get this straight he's been
forever trying to decode
a completely made-up language that
doesn't exist anywhere that you've never
seen anywhere
all you got was pre-recorded here you're
like it's
something whatever i'm not gonna spend
much time on that one
you don't spend enough time with swords
on the sword boss
swords are way cooler than shacks but in
all sincerity just you even trying to
sound out what those letters might be is
more work than we've ever done
ever i like how when loki hits the
ground outside the train he makes the
same plank pose that he did when hitting
the sanctum floor after falling for 30
minutes in ragnarok and then he reveals
the temp pad but it
is broken though again perhaps what we
are looking at here is just part of an
illusion by loki to manipulate sylvie
into revealing exactly how her
enchantment works
because only now does silvi finally
reveal that she mind controls by
reconstructing memories
and she also reveals to loki that the
tba are actually memory-wiped variants
which are big things that loki has
gained through this experience i have
heard
that theory go around quite a bit
already that when he pulls out the temp
pad
that that is an illusion so i've heard
that like loki is making that an
illusion so that way he can get the
information he really wants
but the thing though is they really set
out on this mission
for the ark when all hope is lost in its
final moments
he looks like devastated yeah he looks
like hopeless both having a reaction
to what they're seeing not him trying to
sell a ruse to her
exactly because if he if if it was
really hopeless i don't think he'd look
hope like is he trying to she walks away
and he's just like still
looking to putt it oh no no he's just
standing there going my plan is work
yes the ultimate ruse i feel great at
this moment
which then leads to this seemingly
impossible long take through the
collapsing city of cheru now at first
glance this awesome looking sequence
appears to be a
three minute unbroken long stop but like
any long-term
film it's actually several shots
stitched together with hidden cuts if
you look closely
see the gates closing and then the
camera pants as two runners pass the
frame
touch yeah and there you shot two i love
this
quarterback a few times and then crane
up on a vfx shot of that colliding
planet cracking in half and then a
meteor strike in a nearby building
flashing the frame
cut there now on shot three of them as
they duck from debris and run towards an
explosion that blows them back
tilting the camera and filling the frame
with smoke cut
and then they run into that cafe and
they confront some guards i think there
were some cuts hidden in there on the
stunts but
definitely a cut when the camera passes
a beam on a shot five as they run and
have their weight cut off and they take
cover they follow another running woman
back to that same building that
collapses
crane up on a vfx shot of that collapse
cut there
to shot six where they run and loki
freezes that tower from crushing them
reverses it back up
and then right after as loki runs right
with the whip pan there's a really hard
to spot cut there notice loki's body
from
two different shots are layered on top
of each other barely overlapping
leading the shot motion blur interesting
and so we fight off the last of the
guards at the gate only to see the ark
get destroyed by
meteors as loki's charm foreshadowed we
got some fireworks now
notice that in their last moves loki and
sylvie do these same yeah
yes yes some are saying that loki might
have used a stolen time stone to stop
and reverse that tower collapse but
after that
wanted to summon that i'd later realize
that we've also seen loki use
telekinesis to throw over all the
furniture in that prison cell
ah yes dark world so that time stone
only would have worked as one and twenty
years
is that exact prune timeline that that
time stone was taken from and since
silvi created the whole bunch of
branches with their bombing i just think
it would be
really hard for loki to think ahead so
perfectly also i'm pretty sure we heard
that time stone clunk back in the drawer
really if loki had a functional time
stone here he would have used it in
dozens of ways
cosmic wonder i still really enjoy your
hit video
even though it's been completely
dismantled
here and now in front of our very eyes
again
okay i didn't think that he had the time
stone
only because like what i was saying
about the illusion yeah
with the temp head because of how the
final sh literally the actual final shot
of
loki looking upon the ark being
destroyed that's
why i just like well nah i mean he
wouldn't look so worried well and i feel
like if he had used the time stone to
catch the tower he could have then used
the time stone to maybe reverse the
meteor i think also sylvie would have
taken more notice of what just happened
in that moment yeah
you know being like that's part of our
power set let's go on
yes exactly yeah there's a lot of like
story beats
more so that was making me think that
that wasn't the case
and then he's going with like logical
rules
that's no fun
[Laughter]
way more fun to theorize but i still
believe it is possible that for all of
these events elementor's one or at least
part of sylvie after waking up the train
at some point
could be part of loki's enchantment on
her
designed to gain sylvia's trust to learn
what he needed about the tva
so that he can turn her in and get back
in their good graces
whether or not that's the case not being
quite sure if we're under loki's
enchantment at any given moment is what
makes the show so enchanting i would
invoking how loki called her a poor
photocopy of him
here both are black and white
photocopies all while bonnie guitar's
dark moon plays with the lyrics
paralleling the way loki and silvi's
scheme
was cut off by a dark moon or
it was a planet planet it looked like it
moved but they called it the planet
anyway support this channel by checking
out our new loki inspired merch options
especially that loki out of time shirt
yeah
follow me on instagram and twitter
eaboss follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thank you for watching bye
also notice you update your subscribe
button because there's three million
oh i i would love it if we are under the
god of mischief's enchantment like for
times where we just had no idea we were
that would be a great reveal it's
loki come on let's get the mischief
going the entire tva is
location everything we've seen up until
this
just cuts to loki and thor ragnarok in
the jail so messing with us
just entertaining myself eddie and i did
i actually did completely forget about
the in the jail cell and there how he
does launch those chairs back man oh
yeah we have seen those powers
had to forget about that i love how much
legitimacy the mcu has lately been
lending
for the dark world guys thank you so
much for being here subscribe to new
rockstars if you haven't done so already
keep a lookout for our loki episode 4
reaction
get ready to watch me wear this shirt
for the next three weeks and
the reaction there and then the new rock
stars reaction here
that john humphrey on social media the
greg album
like buttons galore's see you guys you
rock thank you so much for being here